hi well it's nice to be back at
Princeton I find it difficult to believe
that it's been almost 11 years since I
departed these halls for Washington I
wrote recently to inquire about the
status of my leave at the University and
the letter I got back began regrettably
Princeton receives many more qualified
applicants for faculty positions than we
can accommodate I'll extend my best
wishes to the seniors later but first I
want to congratulate the parents and the
families sitting out on the lawn as a
parent myself I know that putting your
kid through college these days is no
walk in the park some years ago I had a
colleague who sent three kids through
Princeton even though neither he nor his
wife attended this University he isn't a
spouse we're very proud of that
accomplishment as they should have been
but my colleague also used to say that
from a financial perspective the
experience was kind of like buying a new
Cadillac every year and then driving it
off a cliff
I should say that he always added he
would do it all over again in a minute
so well done moms and dads this is
indeed an impressive and appropriate
setting for a commencement I'm sure that
from this lectern any number of
distinguished spiritual leaders have
ruminated on the lessons of the ten
commandments I don't have that kind of
confidence and anyway coveting your
neighbor's ox or donkey is not the
problem it used to be so I thought I
would use my few minutes today to make
ten suggestions or maybe just ten
observations about the world and your
lives after Princeton please note these
points have nothing to do with interest
rates my qualification for making such
suggestions or observations
besides being kindly invited to speak
here today by president Tillman is the
same reason that your obnoxious brother
or sister got to go to bed later I am
older than you all of what follows has
been road-tested in real-life situations
but past performance is no guarantee of
future results
number one the poet Robert Burns when
says something about the best laid plans
of mice and men ganging asked agley
whatever agley means a more contemporary
philosopher Forrest Gump said something
similar about life and boxes of
chocolate and not knowing what you're
going to get they were both right life
is amazingly unpredictable any 22 year
old who thinks they know where they will
be in ten years much less than 30 is
simply lacking an imagination
look what happened to me a dozen years
ago I was minding my own business
teaching economics 101 Alexander Hall
and thinking of good excuses for
avoiding faculty meetings then I got a
phone call in case you're skeptical the
Forrest Gump's insight here's a concrete
suggestion for each of the graduating
seniors take a few minutes the first
chance you get and talk to an alum
participating in their 25th or 30th or
40th reunion you know somebody who was
near the front of the pier aid ask them
back when they were graduating 25 30 or
40 years ago where they expected to be
today if you can get them to open up
they'll tell you that today they are
happy and satisfied in various measures
or not and their personal stories will
be filled with highs and lows and
in-betweens but I'm willing to bet those
life stories will in almost all cases be
quite different in large and small ways
from what they expected when they
started out those many years ago this is
a good thing not a bad thing who wants
to know the end of a story that's only
in his early chapters don't be afraid to
let the drama play out too does the fact
that our lives are so influenced by
chance and seemingly small decisions and
actions mean that there's no point to
planning the striving not at all
whatever life may have in store for you
each of you has a grand lifelong project
and that is the development of yourself
as a human being your family and your
friends and your time at Princeton have
given you a good start what will you do
with it
will you keep learning and thinking hard
and critically about the most important
questions we become an emotionally
stronger person more generous more
loving more ethical will you involve
yourself actively and constructively in
the world many things will happen in
your lives pleasant and not so pleasant
but paraphrasing a Woodrow Wilson School
adage from the time I was here wherever
you go there you are if you are not
happy with yourself even the loft East
achievement is not going to bring you
much satisfaction three the concept of
success leads me to consider so-called
meritocracies and their implications
we've been taught that meritocratic
institutions and societies are fair
putting aside the reality that no system
including our own is really entirely
meritocratic meritocratic America sees
may be fairer and more efficient than
some alternatives but are they fair in
an absolute sense think about it a
meritocracy is a system in which the
people who are the luckiest in their
health and genetic endowment luckiest in
terms of family support encouragement
and probably income luckiest in their
educational and career opportunities and
luckiest in so many other ways difficult
to enumerate those are the folks who
read the largest rewards the only way
for even a putative meritocracy to hope
to pass ethical muster to be considered
fair is if those who are the luckiest
and all of those respects also have the
greatest responsibility to work hard to
contribute to the betterment of the
world and to share their luck with
others as the Gospel of Luke says and
I'm sure my rabbi will forgive me for
quoting the New Testament in a good
cause from everyone to whom much has
been given much will be required and
from the one to whom much has been
entrusted even more will be demanded
it's kind of like rating on the curve
for who is worthy of admiration the
admonition from Luke which is shared by
most ethical and philosophical
traditions by the way helps with this
question as well
those most worthy of admiration are
those who have made the best use of
their advantages or alternatively coat
most courageously with their adversities
I think most of us would agree that
people who have say little formal
schooling but labour honestly and
diligently to help feed clothe and
educate their families are deserving of
greater respect and help if necessary
than many people who are superficially
more successful and they're also more
fun to have a beer with that's all that
I know about sociology
five since I've covered what I know
about sociology I might as well say
something about political science as
well in regard to politics
I've always liked Lily Tomlin's line in
paraphrase I try to be cynical but I
just can't keep up we all feel that way
sometimes actually having been in
Washington now for almost 11 years as I
mentioned I feel that way quite a bit
ultimately though cynicism is a poor
substitute for critical thought and
constructive action sure interests and
money and ideology all matter as you
learned in political science but my
experience is that most of our
politicians and policymakers are trying
to do the right thing according to their
own views and consciences most of the
time if you think that the bad or
indifferent results that too often come
out of Washington are due to base
motives and bad intentions you're giving
politicians and policymakers way too
much credit for being effective honest
error in the face of complex and
possibly intractable problems as far
more important source of bad results
than our bad motives for these reasons
the greatest forces in Washington are
ideas and people prepared to act on
ideas public service as I've discovered
is not in it's not easy but in the end
if you're inclined in that direction
it's the worthy and challenging pursue
six have been taking a stab at sociology
and political science let me wrap up
economics while I'm at it
economics is a highly sophisticated
field of thought that is superb at
explaining to policymakers precisely why
the choices they made in the past were
wrong about the future not so much
however a careful economic analysis does
have one important benefit which is that
it can help kill ideas that are
completely logically inconsistent or
wildly at variance with the data
this insight covers at least 90% of
proposed economic policies seven
I'm not going to tell you the money
doesn't matter because you wouldn't
believe me anyway
in fact for too many people around the
world money is literally a life-or-death
proposition but if you're part of the
lucky minority with the ability to
choose remember that money is a means
and not an end a career decision based
only on money and not on love of the
work or desire to make a difference is a
recipe for unhappiness a nobody likes to
fail but failure is an essential part of
life and of learning if your uniform is
in 30 you haven't been in the game 9 I
spoke earlier about definitions of
personal success in an unpredictable
world I hope that as you develop your
own definition of success as you will be
able to do so I hope that you'll be able
to do it with a close companion on your
journey in making that choice remember
that physical beauty is evolutions way
of assuring us that the other person
doesn't have too many intestinal
parasites
don't get me wrong I'm all for beauty
romance and sexual attraction
where would Hollywood and Madison Avenue
be without them but while important
those are not the only things to look
for in a partner the two of you will
have a long trip together I hope and
you'll need each other's support and
sympathy more times than you can count
speaking of somebody who's been happily
married for 35 years I can't imagine any
choice is consequential for a lifelong
journey than a choice of traveling
companion can call your mom and dad once
in a while
a time will come when you'll want your
own grown-up busy hyper successful
children to call you also remember who
paid your tuition to Princeton well
those are my 10 suggestions they're
probably worth exactly what you paid for
them but they come from someone who
shares your affection for this great
institution and who wishes you the best
for the future congratulations graduates
give them hell